hey guys gqueues Jake wolf here since
the dawn of slim shadey guys have been
dyeing their hair blonde in an effort to
add a volt of energy to their personal
style and after seeing male model
sensation lucky blue Smith led up the
runway in Europe and in New York I'm
thinking maybe that I can pull off the
platinum blonde look myself how do you
know how this is going to look before
you do it do I know that I'm gonna look
really great so I know that I'm gonna
look really bad before going in - is
there any way to really know mm well you
should you should gauge what tones you
look best in and that's something that
you know the average guy isn't going to
know so it's better to rely on their
professional so you know I'll be able to
cater the color to what will look best
on your skintone
so before a guy comes into this line or
anything that they should do to prep
their hair for the process it's
absolutely crucial not to have very
recently shampoo your hair gone to the
gym that morning and like done a you
know rough shampoo it basically it's not
going to alter the hair color in any way
it's just really a matter of stripping
your scalp of essential oils and it
needs to sort of you know buffer it from
the stinging of the color I I always
prefer that you see a professional yeah
but you can absolutely 100% do this at
home you can definitely do it you know
YouTube is full of terrible videos and
some actually good advice okay do your
do your research you can always pay for
a consultation with a professional and
then go from there and do it yourself so
what about um I have some pretty
prominent eyebrows and there's probably
a lot of guys out there who maybe aren't
thinning their eyebrows ER or shaping
them the way that a lot of women would
so will that affect the way that it
looks at the end at all I actually think
it looks you know platinum blonde looks
best when you have like a heavier
eyebrow it's just a cooler look but
something you can actually do its best
to keep them as you know natural as
possible to look as masculine as
possible but you can go in very very
lightly um with just thinning shears and
just thin out the bulkiness of them you
look very happy what do you think yeah I
think it's a shock but I think that you
know it looks amazing I think that you
did a absolutely amazing job it was
quite a process
how long do you think this took us today
it was a roughly a four-hour thing now
that I have the
amazing blonde hair what do I have to
know for the next few weeks as it starts
as I'm living with it as people are
going and on you down the streets and
alright huh well the purple shampoo is a
good thing to keep on hand okay yeah you
do a good shampoo with that
that should help brighten it up a bit um
also steer clear of pools if you if you
love it you want to keep up with it two
to three weeks okay that's how long you
should go there you have it everyone if
you want to get hair like lucky blue
Smith or Mark Bronson or Jared Leto or
any of these dudes were dying their hair
blonde this is how you do it I'm Jake
Wolfe
she's Alexis she's Jackie thanks
everyone